[Music]
one of the most extraordinary examples
of beauty happening in the natural world
is the courtship display song of the
club winged mannequin the club wing
mannequin is a South American bird that
sings with its wings the female club
wing does all the nesting and builds the
nests and lays the eggs and takes care
of them all in her own but she chooses
among available mates based on the songs
they sing but they sing with their wing
feathers in a very special way by
shaking their wing feathers rapidly over
their back they create a an electronical
sound that sounds like Wang that rings
out of the forest and yet this is
actually produced by the wing feathers
rubbing together this is interesting
because it shows that beauty can be
innovative birds have been singing songs
with vocal songs with their syrinx for
something like 80 million years but this
bird has essentially abandoned vocal
song to create music in a whole new way
with its wing feathers studies have
shown that as we look inside the body of
the male club wing manikin the wing
bones have been greatly altered too in
order to make this sound what this means
is that beauty is not only skin deep
right in order to make these beautiful
attractive sounds the wing bones have
become elaborated and even solid like
ivory right this is a big deal because
all birds have hollow wing bones even
hey even Velociraptor and t-rex have
hollow arm bones so this is a design
that goes back prior to the origin of
birds and prior to the origin of flight
right but flying birds all maintain
Halloween bones but somehow or other the
male club wing manikin has abandoned
them in order to in order to produce his
wing song now this is interesting
because his wing bones are actually made
worse at flying by his by the compromise
to be beautiful in order to make this
that females love then the male has been
dragged off that that optimal design
toward a new design which functions less
well at flying in other words the males
be made less capable at flight by female
choice that kind of investment or cost
could be rationalized as another kind of
honesty right a kind of handicap that
indicates how good he is that he can
waste energy to make the wing boats I
wanted to test that idea by exploring
what's going on in female clothing
mannequins it turns out that female Club
Wings have the same elaborate thickened
and or a wider wing bones as as the
males yet they will never sing a wing
song how does that work well it turns
out that the wing bones develop in the
embryo in the egg before the the embryo
becomes either male or female and as a
result when the female selects on the
males that she likes with the song that
she likes her female offspring will also
inherit bizarre wing bones and yet they
won't be made better by them they will
never profit from so in this case of the
club wing manikin both males and females
are made worse off as a result of mate
choice I call this the evolution of
decadence it's an example of how mate
choice our evolution by mate choice can
work in an entirely opposite or opposing
direction to natural selection I think
that's a case of where we are driven to
accept the idea that that beauty happens
[Music]